and she wants to help the helplessness
is agonizing for lisa binhayatska a
ukrainian surgical nurse now a refugee
she fled kiev when the fighting started
reuniting in latvia with her childhood
best friend olga lefkowska
she's been welcomed but lisa wants
nothing more than to go back and help
are you afraid to go back
no
no she wants to call right now
i'm stopping her because i don't think
that's safe and she's definitely not
going to help anyone when she's dead
these women don't know if or when they
can go home but they have one plea for
western governments in nato create a
no-fly zone over ukraine we understand
why why nato doesn't want to do that but
this is
this is very important for us and this
is
urgent we put that plea to the defense
minister here in riga i feel
extremely empathetic to that sentiment
but anita anand says the risk of war
between the u.s and russia to rival
nuclear powers is too great enforcing a
no-fly zone
would
lead to a severe
and certain escalation
of hostilities but there might be
another way canada can help ukraine with
aerial support
this is the bairakhtar combat drone it's
been used with devastating effectiveness
by the ukrainian military
images of its strikes can be found
online and over social media its
precision camera is canadian made anand
says the government is looking at
supplying more of that technology to
ukraine we are
actively examining ways in which we
could assist the ukrainian army with
that equipment canada has promised
anti-tank weapons as well to support
ukrainian forces but military sources
tell global news there are major
challenges in delivering them the
minister would not confirm or deny that
but insisted the weapons will make it to
people in ukraine i have been assured
through our sources that our aid will be
able to flow and at this point that's
all i can say until it is successfully
and safely delivered for now ukrainians
are desperate for any help they hope is
coming soon
as for canada's capabilities the defense
minister hinted at increased defense
spending and possibly accelerated
procurements on things like new fighter
jets in the near future
donna all right mercedes stevenson in
riga latvia tonight